-Ah! December --
my favorite time of year.
And I think you all know why.
Ho ho ho!
But, here, let me explain it
to you with a song.
♪ It's that wonderful, special
time of year ♪
♪ I fly around the world
spreading Christmas cheer ♪
♪ I ride on my sleigh
with my eight reindeer ♪
♪ And now my friend,
Santa Nas X, is here ♪
-♪ Thank you, Santa, my bitch,
man, I'm ready to party ♪
♪ And I'm flyin' in my sleigh
while I'm chuggin' Bacardi ♪
♪ And I got a big bag,
which you already know ♪
♪ Got a couple candy canes
for my ho-ho-hoes ♪
-[ Chuckles ] A-anyway...
♪ I live at the North Pole
with my wife ♪
♪ And many happy elves,
it's a happy life ♪
♪ I have rosy cheeks
and I wear a red suit ♪
♪ And I top it all off with my
big, black boots ♪
-♪ [Bleep] your black boots,
man, I got Jimmy Choos ♪
♪ And I got a Lamborghini,
just kiddin', I got two ♪
♪ I'm decked out in chrome
and I [bleep] on the daily ♪
♪ I don't give presents, bitch,
I make the kids pay me ♪
-Maybe we should
stop doing the song.
-Hell no, you red-nosed bastard.
I'm just getting started.
-Okay.
♪ When I stop by,
give me cookies and milk ♪
-♪ Nah, I can't eat that [bleep]
boy, I got a new grille ♪
-♪ Have a little eggnog,
but not too much ♪
-♪ [Bleep] your nog, give me
Henny in a big-ass cup ♪
-♪ I've got to be honest,
you might deserve coal ♪
-♪ I'mma turn that [bleep] to
diamond and buy the North Pole ♪
-♪ I should have done a song
with Rudolph or Frosty ♪
-♪ You like to be nice,
well, I like to get naughty ♪
♪ Naughty, naughty, naughty ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Let's get
naughty, turn up the track ♪
♪ Grab my sack
while I count these stacks ♪
♪ Don't need reindeer,
that's a fact ♪
♪ Got my hoes out front
and some presents in the back ♪
♪ [Bleep] your
stocking stuffin' ♪
♪ Nobody's gettin' nothin' ♪
-Alright,
I've -- I've heard enough.
This isn't what Christmas
is all about.
Christmas is about
presents under the tree
and Rudolph and gingerbread men.
It's about tradition and lights
and whispering what you want
while you sit on my lap.
-Oh, you nasty, huh?
-No, no, no!
That's not what I meant.
-♪ Yeah, let's get
naughty, turn up the track ♪
♪ Grab my sack
while I count these stacks ♪
♪ Don't need reindeer,
that's a fact ♪
♪ Got my hoes out front
and some presents in the back ♪
♪ Claus and Nas
are here to stay ♪
♪ Merry Christmas,
happy holidays ♪
-Okay, go stream
"HOLIDAY" now.
[ Bells jingle ]